in the last video I hinted that things
were about to get wacky and they are so
if we start where we left off in the
last video we started right over here
looking at the distance tool to the
nearest star and just as a reminder in
this drawing right here this depiction
right here this circle right here this
solar system circle it's not the size of
the Sun it's not the size of the orbits
of the earth or Pluto or the creeper
belt this is close to the size of the
Oort cloud and the actual orbit of Earth
is about one
well the diameter of the orbit of Earth
is about 150 thousandth of this so you
wouldn't even see it on this it would
not even make up a pixel on this screen
right here much less much less the
actual size of the Sun or something much
smaller and that and just to remember
that orbit of the earth that was at that
huge distance it takes 8 minutes to get
from for light to get from the Sun to
there this super long distance if you
shot a bullet at the Sun from Earth it
would take you that 17 years to actually
get to the Sun so once again this huge
distance wouldn't even show up on this
picture now what we saw in the last
video is if you travel it unimaginably
fast speeds if you travel at 60,000
60,000 kilometers per hour and I picked
that speed because that's how fast
Voyager 1 actually is traveling that's
one of the I think the fastest object we
have out there in space right here and
it's actually kind of leaving the solar
system as we speak but even if you were
able to get that fast it would still
take it would still take eighty thousand
years 75 or 80 thousand years to travel
the 4.2 light years to the Alpha
Centauri cluster of stars to the nearest
star it would take 80 thousand years 80
thousand years and that scale of time is
already amount of time that I have
trouble comprehending you can imagine
all of modern civilization has occurred
in well definitely in the last 10,000
years but most of recorded history is in
the last four or five thousand years so
this is 80,000 years to travel to the
nearest star so it's a huge distance
another way to think about it is if if
the Sun if the Sun were the size of a
basketball and you put that basketball
in London if you wanted to do it in
scale the next closest star which is
actually a smaller basketball right over
here Proxima Centauri that's smaller
basketball you would have to put in Kiev
Ukraine Kiev Ukraine in order to have a
similar scale so these are basketballs
sitting in these cities and you would
have to travel about 1,200 miles to
place the next basketball and these
basketballs are representing these super
huge things that we saw in the first
video the Sun if you actually made the
earth relative to these basketballs
these would be little grains of sand so
if there are any little small planets
near over here you they would have to be
grains of sand in Kiev Ukraine versus
the grain of sand in London so this is a
massive massive distance already at
least in my mind unimaginable and when
it gets really Rocky is when you start
realizing that this even this is a super
super small distance relative to the
Galactic scale so this whole depiction
of kind of our neighborhood of stars
this thing over here and this thing over
here is about this thing over here is
about give or take and we're doing rough
estimates right here so it's about 30
light years 30 30 light years I'll just
do ly for short so that's about 30 light
years now and once again you cannot
actually you can you can take pictures
of our galaxy from our point of view but
you actually can't take a picture of the
whole galaxy from above it so these are
going to be artist depictions but if
this is 30 light years this drawing
right here of kind of our local
neighborhood of the galaxy this right
here is roughly these are all
approximate approximations this is about
let me do this in a darker color this is
about 1000 1000 light years and this is
the thousand light years of our Suns
neighborhood if you can even call it a
neighborhood anymore even this isn't
really a neighborhood if it takes you
eighty thousand years to get to your
nearest neighbor but this whole drawing
over here it would take forever to get
anywhere over here it
would be one thirtieth of this so it
would be about about that big
this whole drawing and what's really
going to blow your mind is this would be
roughly a little bit more than a pixel
on this drawing right here that spans a
thousand light years but then when you
start to really put into perspective
so now let's zoom out a little bit so
this drawing right here this thousand
light years is now this thousand light
years over here so this is our the local
vicinity of the Sun and I you know once
again the word local is used in very in
a very liberal way at this point so this
right here is a thousand light years a
thousand light years if you're sitting
here if you're sitting here and you're
looking at an object that's sitting let
me do this in a darker color if we're
sitting here on earth and we're looking
at an object out here that's five
hundred light years away we're looking
at it as it was five hundred years ago
because the light that is reaching our
eyeballs right now or our or our
telescopes right now left this guy over
here five hundred years ago I'm sorry
right five hundred years ago in fact
he's not going to even be there anymore
he was probably has moved around a
little bit so just even on this scale
we're already talked about these
unimaginably huge distances and then
when we zoom out this is kind of our
local part of the galaxy right over here
this piece right here this is called or
the Orion spur and people are still
trying to work out exactly what the
actual the details of the actual shape
of the Milky Way galaxy the galaxy that
we're in but but we're pretty sure you
know we actually we're very sure we have
these spiral arms and we have these
Spurs off of them but it's actually very
hard to come up with the actual shape
especially because you can't see a lot
of the galaxy because it's kind of on
the other side on the other side of the
center but really just to get a sense of
something that at least I mean it blows
my mind if you really think about what
it's saying this these unbelievable
distances show up as a little dot here
this whole drawing shows up as a dot
here now when we zoom out over here that
dot would no longer even show up it
wouldn't even register a pixel on this
drawing right over here and then this
whole drawing this whole thing right
over here this whole picture is is this
grid
is this grid right over here it is this
right over here so hopefully that gives
you a sense of how small how small even
our local neighborhood is relative to
the galaxy as a whole and the galaxy as
a whole just to give you a sense has 200
200 to 400 billion billion stars billion
stars or maybe I should say solar
systems just to give you a sense that
you know we saw the social it's not just
the Sun there's all this neat dynamic
stuff and their planets and asteroids
and-and-and solar winds and so there's
there's 200 to 400 billion stars and for
the most part 200 and 400 billion solar
systems so it's an unimaginably uh I
guess a complex or or huge place and
just to you know make it clear you know
even when we zoom in to this picture
right here and I think it was obvious
based on telling you about this that
these little you know white pockets
right here these aren't this isn't one
star this isn't two sorry these are
thousands of stars here so when you go
over here each little blotch of white
that you see that's not a star that's
not a thousand stars we're trying to
talk in the millions of stars when you
look at certain blotches here and there
I mean maybe it might be one star that's
closer to you or it might be a million
stars that are far apart and that are
just relatively close together and
everything has to be used in kind of
loose terms here and we'll talk more
about other galaxies but even this isn't
the upper bound of galaxies people
believe the andromeda galaxy has a
trillion stars and it truly in solar
systems we're talking about this huge
huge immense distances and so just to
give you a sense of where we fit in the
picture this is the rough location of
our Sun and remember that little dot I
drew just now is including millions of
stars millions of solar system's already
unimaginable distances but if you really
want to get the sense relative to the
whole the whole galaxy this will this is
an artist's depiction once again we
could never obviously get this
perspective on the galaxy would take us
forever to travel this far so that you
could see the galaxies from above but
this is our best guess looking at things
from our vantage point we actually could
never even see
we actually can't even see this whole
area over here because it's on the other
side of the center of the galaxy which
is super super dense and super bright
and so it's very hard to see things on
the other side we think actually we
there's a supermassive black hole at the
center of the galaxy and we think that
they're at the center of all or most
galaxies but you know the whole point of
this video actually this whole series of
videos this is just kind of I don't know
but MIT put you in all a little bit of
just how huge this is cuz when you
really think about the scales it's it's
I don't know I know no words can really
describe it but just to give you a sense
we're about twenty five thousand we're
about twenty five thousand light-years
let me twenty five thousand light-years
from the center of the galaxy so
whenever even when we look at things in
the center of the galaxy that's as they
were twenty-five thousand years ago it
took twenty five thousand years for that
light to get to us I mean you know when
that light left the center of the galaxy
I don't even I won't even guess to think
what what what what what what humanity
was like at that point in time so it's
it's these huge distances and the whole
galaxy over here and once again like
solar systems it's hard to it's hard to
say the edge of the galaxy because
there's always going to be a few more
stars and other things orbiting around
the galaxy as you go further and further
out but it gets less dense with stars
but the main density the main disk is
about a hundred thousand light years
100,000 light years is the diameter
roughly of the of the main part of the
galaxy and it's about a thousand light
years thick so you kind of imagine it as
this disk this thing that's fairly flat
but it's a thousand light years thick
it's a thousand light years thick you
would have to do you would have to do
you would have to do this distance you
would have to do this distance 250 times
just to go from the the top part of the
galaxy to the bottom part much less
going across the galaxy so it's it's it
might seem relatively flat so but it
still immensely immensely thick and this
is another way to visualize it if this
thing right over here that includes the
Oort cloud roughly roughly a Lightyear
in diameter roughly a Lightyear in
diameter is a grain of sand a millimeter
millimeter in diameter grain of sand
then the universe as a whole is going to
be the diameter of a football field and
if that you know that might say okay
those are two tractable things I can
imagine a grain of sand a millimeter a
wide grain of sand in a football field
but remember remember that grain of sand
that grain of sand is still is still 50
or 60 thousand times the diameter of
Earth's orbit and Earth's orbit it would
still take a bullet or something
traveling as fast as a jet plane 15
hours to just go half of that or a
second acted 15 years or 17 years I
forgot the exact number but you know 15
16 17 years to even cover half of that
distance 30 years to cover an entire
diameter of or so 30 years just to cover
the diameter of Earth's orbit that's 160
thousand of our little grain of sand in
the football field and just to kind of
really I don't know I have an
appreciation for for how how am i a mind
blowing this really is this is actually
a picture of the Milky Way galaxy our
galaxy from our vantage point as you can
see we're in the galaxy so we're seeing
and this is looking towards the center
and even this picture you start to
appreciate the complexity of what a
hundred billion stars are but but what I
really want to point out is even in this
picture when you're looking at these
things some of these things that look
like stars those aren't stars those are
thousands of stars or millions of stars
maybe it could be one star closer up but
when we're starting to approach the
center of the galaxy these are thousands
and thousands and millions of stars or
solar systems that we're actually
looking at so it's really it starts to
boggle the mind to imagine what might
actually be going on over there